bader mal abends lud meine lieben
freunde ist ab heute endlich mal wieder
ganz ganz ganz ganz recht herzlich
begrüßen zu einer neuen episode
tinc-news ich würde sagen wir starten
wir wieder mit dem besten tik tok der
woche
[Musik]
[Applaus]
könnte ich mir auch selbst zu senden
[Musik]
ich sagte dass ich was eigenes
ja
[Musik]
die du von
als klar bruder einfach mal entspannter
salz brechen zwei arten von traktoren
der normale drumrum der kaputten traurig
ist hat dass solche leute wirklich gibt
zum beispiel ich bin auch sein
als ich damals im musik
[Musik]
ja
ja nix mehr rostocks doch heute herrscht
fast 60 plus ist unbezahlbar man auf der
windenergie sie wirkungslos mein tipp
ist
was wenn jemand sagt du bist hässlich
sagt einfach
[Musik]
danke für den tipp
einerseits wird
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
die heftige schwalbe
den final
kommt man auf so was seit ich morgens
von kaffee auf franken sind umgestiegen
bin viel glücklicher
mein arzt sagt das liegt wahrscheinlich
an vitamin c und natürlich auch im
zucker aber ich glaube eher das liegt am
wodka das wäre eigentlich so ein
typisches kick noch wasser aufnehmen
müsste all meine freunde waldstück ist
eine straftat
das wird jetzt zur anzeige gebracht hat
er wohl nicht langweilig las vegas schon
der zweite heftige tipp den leute
beigebracht bekommen haben es mit peter
h
luca de meo nur 69 auf wunsch bestellst
csu besser so dass die hat mir
geschrieben ich bin dein schönster
jugend der welt ruft hatten wir mal eine
nummer volk ruft an wenn ihr meine
nummer wollt das macht würden hallo wir
sind der clan laser laser luca ich würde
gerne neuen klagen ist ein kleiner
klaren womit zwei spiele
ok ich würde gerne mal mitmachen
wir holen euch fragen ob wir mit unserer
klaren reinkommen
ja ich bin laser lokal wird keinen neuen
laser klaren veranstalten trainieren und
auch und soweit turniere und auch und so
weiter da bin ich dabei diesen bekannten
snacken einen guten zeiten nicht nur zum
kneippen sondern auch zum guten bleiben
da bin ich dabei maximal zehn jenischen
sieg gehört auch immer 19 mit dazu
maximal zum jeden epischen sie gehört
auch ein snipes' dazu
das sehe ich auch so tja
tja
mehr hereinkommen will es wäre sehr nett
von euch ja ich bin ich bin sehr nett
und ich heiße habe auch laser dem namen
und wieder klarheit und ich glaube ich
bin noch einmal seinen guten also ich
bin dabei
wir sind extra schluss kopf trinken ganz
ruhig wirklich dass mussawi an gekannt
die post ab
[Musik]
hast du denn die lustig denn nicht nur
kosten der mission gold winkt esta
ruppin bei der new venue soll des
priesters eltern lafeo alles klappt
alles klar
was los allagui springt er hätte sich
nicht an
auf diesem schild steht bisher nur zwei
personen entgegen dabei besteht unsere
games mehr als zwei personen
[Musik]
was schaue ich mir an
die geister das ist so warum solche
komischen hat euch ferrari guckt mal
nach draußen was der wiese nichts bist
du behindert kannst du dich lesen was da
auf dem spiel steht
das liest ist ein
warum warum finde ich das so witzig also
ja ich weiß dietmar mieth rennen mit
diesem konrad kopf von der alien wollte
er kommt aus amerika und gefühlt ist ja
alles optik doch einfach nur einer macht
dass alle anderen clown das variieren
das ändern das aber ist so witzig er ist
so nah ist
[Musik]
ja da gibt es halt auch noch solche
leute hallo leute wir sind hier wir sind
richtig viele vögel jetzt passt auf das
sind locker 300 ich schätze mal hätten
mache das noch so viel lustiger
[Musik]
ernst
das richtige mega nach los sein
was ist los sein
nix mehr süßes
ihr habt humor studios das wichtigste
bei einer frau aus die persönlichkeit
perfekt davon am streit tödlich für die
tiere ein kleiner weise voll einbinden
und eingang der gemacht hat ist dumm
ich frage mich manchmal
die ich meinen beruf
älteren leuten beschreiben würde ich
will geist nicht ganz gesund die lange
linie mai
[Musik]
hunde sind so lustig bald soweit sich
war auch gestern in hamburg und habe
dort auch einfach völlig rennen im
kleinen goldenen schimmer welten gewesen
das ist ein ganz kleiner golden
retriever welt ist das ein spiel bei dem
man das figürchen nach vorne bewegt
indem man singt und schreit solche
sommerspielen das daumen hoch und ein
video da aber jetzt kommt auch erstmal
zum letzten titel video bei dem wir eine
krasse bei zeit erfahren freute sich am
morgen vertreibt kummer uns ja an der
haltstelle wirklich heutige wieso die
tickets selbst allerdings haben beide
lieben freunde wie bereits gesagt hast
ja noch einen daumen hoch unter dem
video hier da schreibt mir euren tipp
namen runden in die kommentare wenn ihr
eventuell die nächste folge tic toc
tools elbe rhein bleiben
ihr wisst was ich meine und jetzt
befinden uns auch im auto meine lieben
freunde hier oben findet ihr in zwei
jahren gewinne werde darauf könnte
meinen kanal kostenlos abonnieren und
verpasst keine systematischen
meisterwerke hier mehr auf meinem kann
halt wahnsinn würde ich direkt machen
und hier ist die letzte folge verlinkt
von tik tok you stayed ist ja schon zwei
oder drei wochen eher weil ich zwei
wochen vergessen habe also klickt